aber bei david lugert herzlich
willkommen ja heute bei der lieben
freunde zu einer neuen episode
ihr seht schon ich befinde mich gerade
nicht in meinem aufnahme zimmer in köln
sondern in meinem alten kinderzimmer bei
meiner familie in bielefeld von der
story für den schlechten ton allerdings
würde ich sagen wir ringen mit dem
ersten whatsapp fällt ihr schreibt eine
person einfach doppelpunkt es also einen
verwirrten smiley und sein
beziehungsweise ihr freunde ziehen wir
so freundin antwortet dann einfach ganz
stumpf auch dieses mal die mit solch uns
gleich was kotzen
ich glaube der wollte kochen schreiben
nicht gerade schon bei kurzer also etwas
ekelhaften sind willig sein machen wir
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten umfeld
und zwar schritt hier jemand ich bin
jetzt bei media markt habe auch
durchfall
nein keinen durchfall duschgel das ist
wieder autokorrektur at its best hey
sorry dass ich mich nicht gemeldet haben
muss lernen und wie weit bist du und für
was lernst du eigentlich in staffel drei
voll gefüllt das kennt glaub ich jeder
ich habe gerade klausurphase eine folge
geht doch und sehen schon später hat man
die ganze staffel durch die kennst du ne
app wo man bilder schöner machen kann
glaubt mir das hilft dir nichts dazu
sage ich nur dass hier nun kommen wir zu
einer nachricht wie so oft sehe ich
meine mutter hätte schreiben können und
zwar was soll dieser arch mit gut hinter
jeder nachricht und ich habe mich
gefragt was für'n arsch mit ruth den
heute das leben
arch mit wo wir allerdings grad schon
bei typischen eltern nachrichten sind
dann würde ich sagen machen wir direkt
mit dem nächsten gold und zwar schreibt
hier eine person irgendwas stimmt nicht
mit meinem iphone ich glaube bei den
nachrichten kommen nicht an daraufhin
schreibt dann die andere person ja die
kommen an
woher willst du das so genau wissen eine
ahnung jäger vielleicht weil wir ihm die
nachrichten ankommen als erstes bekommt
ihr eine person eine sms von seinem
telekommunikationsanbieter und zwar von
vodafone zugeschickt und zwar hatte er
seinen vertrag anscheinend gekündigt
deswegen schreibt vodafone ihr lieber
vodafone kunde geben sie uns die
gelegenheit über übrigen kündigung zu
reden und eigentlich geht mir darauf
nicht mehr ein
er schreibt allerdings ich rede nicht
mehr mit euch ihr seid die meine hektar
wollt ihr mal reden wir sitzen spät ist
lebt wohl neuer f funk nach sie da hat
er recht wenn man an zwei stellen
schmerzen hat reicht an eine
schmerztablette ja du musst dir aber
halbieren damit die anteilen stellen
wirken kann ok walker und trägt ein mann
der shirt am sonntag kommt mir
allerdings nun wieder zu einem chat
verlauf von einer tochter mit ihrer
mutter und zwar schreibt die tochter
mama wo bist du gerade vom aldi
parkplatz runter gleich zu hause warum
fragst du süße dabei wir zusammen zumal
die gefahren sind da die mutter
beim aldi vergessen aber wisst ihr was
freunde
wir bleiben direkt bei mama nachrichten
ich schwöre ich habe drogen aber es sagt
drogen was zum teufel ist hier los ich
möchte drogen schreiben kommen sofort
runter und das ist auch so richtig mama
sie hat ein problem mit irgendwas aber
man selbst so hat zu ihr kommen ich
glaube jeder von euch kennt die
situation man sitzt einfach in seinem
zimmer macht ihnen wie seine
hausaufgaben zockt oder chat oder keine
ahnung was und dann auf einmal wird
einfach sein name gerufen
und man denkt sich nur so mama du was
von mir willst dann kommt doch zu mir
wieso solcher zu dir baby ja
sonnenschein voll viele vergleichen ich
mit einem schwein quatsch zwischen dir
und einem schwein ist ein großer
unterschied echt und welcher du bist ja
da würde ich auch eigentlich wieder nur
dass hier ein blenden ich habe gerade
einen richtigen film gesehen da wurde
die ehefrau des typen brutal von einem
serienkiller wurde der sohn klaus gruppe
zurück dann mit einer krassen wendung
mit der sohn entführt der typen muss
dann in den flur a 1000 kilometer jagen
und wird von einer grenzdebilen frauen
unterstützt heftig welcher film war das
diese demo und natürlich nachgedacht und
ja sie mitnehmen wo es eigentlich schon
ist man ziemlich komische film mama der
weihnachtsbaum brenntag schätzchen der
weihnachtsbaum brennt nicht erleuchtet
okay dann läuft wie gardinen und der
schrank jetzt auch dadurch
menschenrechte sind sämtlich abstoßen
ich habe gerade so viel bei chinesen
bestellt dass ich zwei gabeln
mitgenommen habe dann mit ihm ich denke
nicht
man kennt er schreibt mir nicht sicher
sein handy bestimmt hat er eine andere
nicht negativ denken vielleicht würden
immer fan ja nicht effektiv bekommen wir
die chance zum letzten wort fällt für
heute und sein rezept heldin glaube ich
jeder schon mal in seinem leben so
richtig an der eigenen haut erfahren
musste was hast du bei frage 5 im test
geschrieben frage 5 ja auf der rückseite
es gab eine weitere 8
ich sage nur englisch abitur 2014 beende
meine lieben freunde wenn euch diese
episode motzfeld gefallen hat dallas
unbedingt mal einen daumen hoch unter
dem video getan schreibt mir oder in die
kommentare
ob ihr wollt dass ich in einer woche den
nächsten teil watts im fels hochlager
ich möchte zum ende des videos noch mal
ganz kurz etwas sagen uns erkennen die
einen schock
luca - shop.de und heute ist der letzte
tag des monats juni das heißt wenn ihr
heute noch etwas bestellt wird ein euro
von eurer bestellung an die stiftung
gegen rassismus gespendet also ich würde
mich mega freuen wenn ihr bei den neuen
produkten einfach mal im lubminer
shop.de vorbeischauen würde und der
bunte smiley pocket ist nun auch
übrigens wieder auf lager ansonsten main
kanal falls noch kein teil der user die
verpasse keine videos wert ist kostenlos
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]